and rotate might be the most talked
about man in the world why I'm not
totally sure he's made a name for
himself giving advice to anyone and
everyone who will listen now Andrew Tate
has sat down for an interview with Piers
Morgan it has gone completely viral
millions and millions of views I have
not seen it yet but I'm going to watch
and see if I can be a guru to the guru
if I can give any sort of advice to
Andrew Tate on how this interview could
have gone better
foreign
I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false but I've been married
twice as it turns out and on both
occasions I didn't believe that the
woman was being handed to me as chattel
regardless of what Andrew Tate is about
to say or even what was ever was in the
clip I do think he made a slight mistake
they're coming out of that clip he
immediately got defensive before Piers
Morgan never asked him questions of
course of course what do you think what
what where that would seem to imply that
something he said was uh demanding of a
defense when if he really believes what
was said in the clip he would just sit
there quietly and sort of confidently
and wait for the question to be asked so
already I could see how this interview
started to go wrong because already he
started out from a position of Defending
and trying to explain a little and you
know if you're in that defensive
position you're already losing so would
you rephrase what you said there now
what that's that's an interesting point
about phrasing the way I would say
things before I was famous I have to
take personal responsibility and accept
right that if I make a video that 500
people see and one percent of them
misunderstand it that's not a problem if
I make a video that 5 million people see
and one percent of them under so
specifically on that point I think my
sister is a husband's property she took
his last name she she married him she
wanted to join his family she has seen
it herself right so this is just not a
good argument if if he's saying man has
a leadership role in the household or
even you know man is the head of woman
as Christ is the head of the church or
something like that that would be one
thing but to say that therefore because
she takes his name she's his property
that doesn't make sense this is this
leftisters tumbler is my property it's
not you know the leftist tears tumbler
Knowles it's just a complete
non-sequitur I think the argument he's
making is a wrong one to begin with
which is why Piers Morgan is attacking
him but he's not doing a very good job
defending it listen my friend if you
want to argue about this you need to go
back to the Bible to the Quran you need
to argue with religious talk about
anything in the Bible of Quran that's
what it says no no I'm asking you what
you think I think that if a woman
marries a man and she decides to take
his last name that they have different
roles and responsibilities within that
marriage and I believe that that's not
the question true I believe
the father hands her to the man Rob
don't be a politician because I think
you're a straight talker right you keep
telling me you're straight talk I think
my sister is her husband's property do
you regret saying it like that I
understand that with my newfound Fame
perhaps it could be phrased differently
however I still believe that a woman is
given to the man in America he's in a
tough position because it's just it's
just a false statement it just isn't
true I'm pretty Trad you know I totally
love uh gender roles and I believe in
marriage as a marriage is traditionally
understood and I I'm on board with all
of that but it just is not the case that
the wife is the property of the husband
to be considered like all of the
husband's other property that is not a
Christian understanding of marriage and
that is not the traditional
understanding of marriage within our own
culture so it's an indefensible position
I don't know if Tate believes it or not
he keeps saying well I would have you
know maybe you know I offended some
people or they misunderstood it or
whatever but it's just it's just a
losing Point either he could change his
opinion or he could just move on but
there's no way that he's going to win by
doubling down on something that just
isn't isn't true yeah but not as
property now the properties
people use
marriage actually means he's showing you
here why he is losing to peers In This
Moment he's he's ex when he's trying to
explain what happened in these previous
interviews he goes yeah but property
that's not my word that's the word that
was used in the questions right and it's
your responsibility when you're
conveying your arguments to not just
take the bait and all the kind of
leading silly premises of the questions
that you're asked you might be asked
some dumb question hey Andrew Tate when
was the last time you beat your wife to
use a classic example you don't need to
say uh uh uh well it what you know that
that's a that's a silly premise that
sets you up to lose you should reject
the premise and say what are you talking
about property I think
man has a leadership role in the
household
that would be controversial enough
but if you if you take the bait on the
question you're boxing yourself into a
corner and now he doesn't know how to
get out of it they asked all right you
can't blame people for asking you
questions surely if you want to be
accountable the word you said you've got
to own your responses don't blame the
question I own the response let me ask
you a question no and you say something
and then say well I shall blame me for I
understand Pearson peers I understand I
believe the woman is given to the man I
believe she's given away by the father I
believe she belongs to the man so you
she belongs to fundamentally right
that a woman becomes a man's property I
believe she belongs to the man in
marriage correct right
that to me is misogyny and you're
entitled to your opinion right but do
you want do you not understand why
people think it is misogyny I understand
why some people can be very offended by
what I say what they do is they take a
point like that and they ignore all the
other points I make the other way right
that's why that's why I've repeatedly
asked you about that line to see if
you've changed your position but the
reality is you haven't it's not about
changing positions I'm a full-grown
adult and I stick by the things I see
the reality is he has which is which by
the way is fine absolutely so we can
tell that's what he's trying to get out
of this little exchange you said you
know I wouldn't maybe say things the
same way now that I did before I was
famous and yet actually you've doubled
down it's an exactly the same thing on
certain points so that is what you
believe that's my point yes I'm trying
to work out look I don't know you we've
just met right yeah I'm trying to work
out who Andrew Tate is and what you
actually believe I don't want to twist
anything at all that maybe make it very
very clear to the camera I believe a
woman is given to the man in marriage I
believe that I also believe a man has a
duty to protect and provide for her he's
obviously saying that a woman is not
property right to say a woman is given
to a man in marriage and that a woman
that the wife belongs to the husband in
a very deep sense that's very different
than saying the woman Belongs To The Man
in the way that the leftist tears
tumbler belongs to me as property and to
say that the man has a responsibility
toward the woman to protect the woman
that's very different than saying the
woman is property I don't have a
responsibility to protect my left to
steers Tumblr I could throw it against a
wall and go buy a new one man can't do
the same thing for his wife or at least
he certainly shouldn't do that so and
what peers wants to do here is also sort
of dishonest because he keeps trying to
say that's still your opinion that's
still your opinion but if you're
listening to what Andrew said is saying
he's clearly saying that is not my
opinion the implication I think is I
said a dumb completely indefensible
thing but I don't want to admit that I
said a dumb indefensible thing so I'm
trying to both defend my view I'm trying
to say I stand by my views but then
change the view in what I'm explaining
and it's just
difficult to listen to if something
happens or his wife's life is threatened
I believe that when women and children
first are on the light boat lifeboats
but I believe that men but a man doesn't
own a woman it's not no it's honestly
literally buy them as a slave well
obviously we're not talking about that
we're talking about religious biblical
marriage we're talking about something
else yeah but I'm a Christian I don't
believe that I I I I own my wife do you
believe your wife was given away to you
when she took her last name I believe
that there is a process where a father
traditionally walks his daughter down
the aisle and hands his daughter to this
man and they stand there and become a
union of two loving people in a
partnership no because there's no
ownership involved I didn't say he's not
selling her the Father of the Bride
isn't selling his daughter no absolutely
that's what profitable means she becomes
a member of your family I think we're
arguing over semantics we're not there
because fundamentally I don't believe
you are but semantics means meaning so
yes we are always our semantics but I
don't think we live in the world of
slavery I don't own any man or any woman
right nobody owns it when you use
phrases like property that's what you
apply and so my point again is you're a
smart guy right there's no denying that
you're a smart you're a good talker I've
seen a lot of the stuff what I don't
think you quite fully understand no I
understand when young impressionable
people I understand you are not as smart
see things like I think my sister is a
husband's property yes and you've just
reaffirmed that that belief they think
that they have the right to own women I
understand that very well Pierce which
that's why people think you're a
misogynist completely I understand all
of this very well which is why when
you're saying I was backtracking I'm not
I'm generally regret though over the way
you phrased this stuff well this is the
point I was trying to make
the point I'm trying to make is when I
was not nearly as famous and I was
making long format content I was not
sitting there anticipating I've become
the most Googled man in the planet and
that few seconds can be taken out of
context that was not my anticipation but
it's not what you believed it's what you
believe now so what's the difference
it's manifestly not what he believes you
just listen to what he's saying he said
to me look look honestly I've had time
to think about it he just doesn't want
to admit he's wrong I don't believe that
that's one thing actually you've said
the opposite you said actually that's
what I think yeah I think that when uh
so it doesn't really matter whether you
recorded it with your famous or not
famous it's what you actually believe
right I believe that a man has a duty to
protect and provide for a woman I
believe that a woman's father gives her
away to the man that's what I believe
and that's in in my marriage that's
that's the circumstance I'm going to
live under if people want to live in a
different scenario that's completely
theirs they're prerogative you went on
to say about authority over women if I
have a responsibility over I must have a
degree of authority yeah for the same
reason if I have responsibility of
different people are going to use their
mind it's an example an energy
responsibility over a child I have to
have some Authority so you believe as
part of your ownership or your property
of of the woman you have authority over
her now I believe if you ever that's
what you said I believe you've ever
responsibility over something you have
to have a degree of authority you can't
be responsible
again you're the boss the point I'm
making yeah if you're pleased with that
from this point the point I was trying
to make was talking about the safety of
a woman so now now Andrew Tate
he's almost it's almost the opposite
problem in the first part the first part
when he says the woman is the man's
property that's just silly and it's not
true and he shouldn't defend it and if
he doesn't want to come off as weak and
like he's backtracking then he should
just try to move on and say yeah
whatever here's what I believe you ask
me what I believe here's what I believe
I just told you what I believe and just
move on now he gets to the question of
does does a husband have authority a
certain kind of authority in the
household duh is the is the husband in a
certain sense the boss of the marriage
duh
so here he should just completely double
down but he's so been off-footed and
Piers Morgan is very good at this at
off-fitting people at the very top of
the interview he's soaping off footage
he goes well no actually that's not
exactly what I mean but you should just
double down be like yep absolutely yeah
a husband has a particular Authority in
a marriage so you're
uh yes ultimate
ultimate not a tyranny one hopes one
hopes that is actually the union of two
people into one flesh you know but uh
yes ultimately the man has a leadership
role in the marriage duh deal with it
peers he was too uh strident and and
obstinate in the first answer and I fear
he's not obstinate enough in the second
answer just stand up for you said
something that's perfectly fine stick by
it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]